herzlich willkommen zu einem zdf heute
live gehen sofort zur pk zu den
ergebnissen des corona gipfels über die
beratung es geht umgehend loslegen doch
was zurecht legen so meine damen und
herren wir haben ausführlich gezeigt
dass konnten sie verfolgen und wir sind
auch zu einem guten ende gekommen unter
den schwierigen bedingungen
ich kann also über eine intensive und
konstruktive zusammenarbeit zwischen
bund und ländern berichten nicht nur
heute nachmittag sondern auch bei den
letzten tagen der vorbereitung möchte
mich auch ganz herzlich bei den ländern
bedanken die einen großen teil ja auch
dazu beigetragen haben wir nähern uns
dem ende des monats november und wir
hatten ja am 28 oktober in dieser runde
einschneidende und befristete maßnahmen
beschlossen
und heute haben wir wie vereinbart
unsere schlussfolgerung aus dem november
gezogen und uns auf einen weg durch die
kommenden und für die kommenden wochen
geeinigt sie wissen dass wir dies für
einen längeren zeitraum und nicht nur
für zwei oder drei wochen machen wollten
wir sind uns in unserer einschätzung wie
die maßnahmen sich ausgewirkt haben
einig der exponentielle anstieg der
infizierten zahlen ist gebrochen
aus der steil ansteigenden kurve sein
flacher verlauf ein flacher verlauf
geworden
aber das ist nur ein teilerfolg er hat
uns hunderttausende von infektionen
erspart damit auch eine überlastung
unseres gesundheitssystems und viele
todesfälle
aber wir können uns mit diesem
teilerfolg auf gar keinen fall begnügen
die täglichen infektionszahlen verhauen
noch auf einem viel zu hohen plateau in
den intensivstationen wird zurzeit
enormes geleistet von meiner seite aus
ein herzliches dankeschön an ärzte und
pfleger und pflegerinnen viele kommen
bereits an ihre grenzen und die
nachricht des robert koch instituts das
in den letzten 24 stunden
410 menschen an profit 19 gestorben sind
erinnert uns auf traurigste weise daran
dass hinter den statistiken eben
menschliche schicksale stehen lebenswege
die zum teil auch viel zu früh enden und
das lässt familien tief trauern um ihre
liebsten und deshalb ist es ein tag an
dem wir heute für die bürgerinnen und
bürger zwei botschaften haben einmal
danke danke dass auch in den letzten
wochen und mund in den letzten wochen
die menschen in ihrer großen mehrheit
die gravierenden einschränkungen erneut
solidarisch mitgetragen haben und das
andere ist die klare aussage von bund
und ländern dass die lage es uns nicht
erlaubt die november maßnahmen
aufzuheben
wir sind noch viel zu weit von dem
zielwert von 50 als incidents pro 100000
einwohner in sieben tagen entfernt
ich bin weiter überzeugt und auch darin
waren wir uns heute eigentlich wir
müssen dieses ziel weiter verfolgen
es ist nicht der einzige wert an dem wir
messen wo wir stehen in der pandemie
aber es ist der wert der darüber
entscheidet ob unser öffentlicher
gesundheitsdienst athen infektion
vollständig nachverfolgen und
infektionsketten unterbrechen kann oder
ob er dazu schlichtweg nicht mehr in der
lage ist die ist zurzeit in den
allermeisten landkreisen leider der fall
ist wir waren uns ja bewusst dass die
menschen von uns heute klarheit wollen
für den rest dieses jahres das ist ihr
recht und wir haben genau in diesem
sinne diskutiert es ist ein besonderer
monat der vor uns liegt der dezember ein
monat mit weihnachten und dem
jahreswechsel ganz besonders wichtige
tage gerade auch für die christen aber
auch für familien insgesamt und wir
haben das in unseren beschlüssen
berücksichtigt es kommt jetzt weiterhin
auf jeden und jede einzelne ansteckungen
geschehen überall dort wo menschen
einander zu eng oder zu unvorsichtig
begegnen und wir alle sind daher
dringend aufgefordert alle vermeidbaren
also sind alle nicht zwingenden kontakte
zu vermeiden
nicht zwingend notwendige reisen nicht
anzutreten und auch in begegnungen nicht
stattfinden zu lassen und möglichst zu
hause zu bleiben
ich werde ihnen gleich einzelheiten der
beschlüsse erläutern möchte aber noch
einmal zusammengefasst sagen wir
brauchen noch einmal eine
kraftanstrengung geduld solidarität
disziplin werden noch einmal auf eine
harte probe gestellt
vieles deutet darauf hin dass 2021 uns
erleichterung bringt und diese
hoffnungsvolle gedanke gerade im blick
auf die impfstoffe ist vielleicht etwas
was uns hilft schritt für schritt dann
die pandemie zu überwinden und bis dahin
noch die geduld die solidarität
aufzubringen wenn ich die beschlüsse im
einzelnen kurz skizzieren dann heißt es
also weiter jeden nicht notwendigen
kontakt vermeiden
wir wollen und die arbeitgeber bitten
jede alle möglichkeiten für home office
zu nutzen insbesondere auch zu
ermöglichen zwischen den feiertagen
gegebenenfalls betriebsferien zu machen
oder menschen zu hause arbeiten zu
lassen
die bundesregierung wird gebeten gerade
was reisen ins europäische ausland
anbelangt in skigebiete zum beispiel zu
versuchen mit europäischen nachbarn zu
koordinieren ich sage ganz offen das
wird wahrscheinlich nicht einfach aber
wir werden zu versuchen die maßnahmen
vom 28 oktober werden also alle
fortgeführt erst einmal bis zum 20
dezember und wir gehen aber davon aus
dass sich bund und länder einig das
wegen des sehr hohen infektionsgeschehen
es die beschränkungen nach menschlichem
ermessen bis anfang januar gelten müssen
es sei denn wir haben einen unerwarteten
rückgang der infektionen unter 50 pro
100000 einwohner in sieben tagen
aber das ist leider im augenblick nicht
absehbar wir haben einige zusätzliche
maßnahmen ergriffen
das müssen wir tun damit wir aus dem
plateau der infektionszahlen
herunterkommen
wir werden bei kleineren einkaufsläden
das gilt heute schon ein
ein quadratmeter zahl von 10 für pro
kunden haben und bei einkaufsflächen
über 800 quadratmeter 20 quadratmeter
für jeden einzulassen den kunden und
ganz wichtig ist dass bei
einkaufszentren hier die jeweilige
gesamtverkaufsfläche anzusetzen ist
abweichungen können länder die eine
kleine incidents haben also weniger als
50 pro 100000 zu lassen das sind im
augenblick kommen dafür zwei
bundesländer infrage schleswig holstein
und mecklenburg vorpommern
aber wir haben vor allen dingen auch
darüber gesprochen dass auch härtere
maßnahmen ins auge gefasst werden müssen
hier ist es so dass wir ein ja sowieso
eine hotspot strategie haben zwischen
bund und ländern die haben wir schon
viel mehr als vereinbart die gilt ab 50
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner da
sind sofort ein konsequentes
beschränktes konzept notwendig und bei
weiter steigenden infektionsgeschehen
müssen dann zusätzliche maßnahmen
unternommen werden
und wir haben uns heute zusätzlich dazu
dieses hot spot konzept gilt weiter bei
besonders extremen infektions lagen wo
es eine indiz von über 200 neue
infektionen pro 100.000 einwohner und
woche gibt und das infektionsgeschehen
diffus ist damit beschäftigt das dann
noch einmal umfassende allgemeinen
maßnahmen noch einmal erweitert werden
sollten und kurz um kurzfristig eine
absenkung zu erreichen
ich will für die bundesrepublik sagen
das betrifft zwar zeit wenn man das land
berlin malz einer einheit nimmt berlin
und 62 weitere kreise landkreise in
denen überlegt werden muss wie man
situationsangepasst zusätzlich zu dem
was bundesweit gilt noch einmal
gegebenenfalls weitere maßnahmen
einleiten muss die werden regional
sicherlich variieren
wir haben auch landkreise mit über 300
incident und da wird man sicherlich dann
noch mal vorangehen müssen
es wird die mund nasen schutz
pflicht zum tragen von nasenschutz noch
einmal sehr stark intensiviert alle orte
mit publikumsverkehr in den innenstädten
betriebs und arbeitsstätten
es wird bei hochschulen und unis auf
digitalen ära umgestellt mit bestimmten
ausnahmen im laborbetrieb und ähnlichem
und wir reduzieren noch einmal die
kontakte auf fünf menschen mit aus mit
zwei haus ständen wobei die kinder unter
14 ausgenommen werden also dazu gezählt
werden können
das ist gegenüber der vorwoche noch
einmal eine verschärfung damit wir dann
zu den weihnachtstagen vom 23 12 bis
längstens erster januar ein fest im
engsten familien und freundeskreis mit
maximal zehn personen feiern können
kinder die dazugehören unter 14 zählen
auch hier nicht es wird das gespräch mit
den religionsgemeinschaften gesucht
damit es keine großveranstaltung gibt im
zusammenhang mit feierlichkeiten zum
weihnachtsfest und wir haben sehr lange
darüber gesprochen dass wir uns ja einig
sind die schulen offen zu halten
aber wir haben an dieser stelle gesagt
was machen wir wenn es dann doch wieder
in bereichen sehr hohe instanz ist und
hier sind einige erweiternde maßnahmen
hinzugekommen auf der einen seite die
pflicht dann auch in den höheren
jahrgängen zum tragen eines mundschutzes
auch in allen bereichen ist der schule
und es sollen dann bei instanzen von
über 200 dass es also wieder ein teil
dieser extremen infektions lagen sollen
weitergehende maßnahmen für die
unterrichtsgestaltung in den älteren
jahrgängen ab jahrgangsstufe acht
schüsse spezifisch umgesetzt werden
welche die umsetzung der asl regeln
besser gewährleisten beispielsweise
hybrid und wechsel unterricht das heißt
also aha da ging es im wesentlichen auch
um die abstandsregelung wir haben uns
natürlich mit dem finanziellen ausgleich
befasst der analog zum november dann
auch wieder geleistet werden soll zum
dezember und zusätzlich gibt es dann bis
juni 2021 auch die überbrückungshilfe 3
und ein wichtiger gedanke waren noch auf
den ich eingehen möchte die bullen
gruppen neben den fft zwei masken die
wird zur verfügung stellen wollen haben
wir noch einmal sehr stark daran gedacht
dass menschen in seniorenheimen in
anderen einrichtungen ja auch ein gutes
weihnachtsfest haben müssen das darf
kein weihnachtsfest in einsamkeit sein
und deshalb werden wir hier ganz
besonders auf besuchsmöglichkeiten auch
achten
insgesamt war es eine sehr intensive
diskussion wo ich jetzt auch nicht auf
alle einzelheiten eingehen konnte die
klarheit schafft für die vor uns
liegende zeit die zeigt dass das eine
schwierige zeit sein wird in der wir
weiter daran arbeiten müssen die
fallzahlen pro tag runter zu bekommen
und das heißt von takte weiter
reduzieren deshalb mussten wir an
einigen stellen noch einmal verschärfen
und das ist uns glaube ich gut gelungen
in der kombination mit möglichkeiten für
weihnachten und den jahreswechsel
herzlich regierende bürgermeister ja es
stimmt dass es tatsächlich eine
besondere situation wir haben wieder
viele stunden miteinander diskutiert
obwohl wir glaube das kann man so sagen
so gut und so intensive uns vorbereitet
haben wir selten zuvor und auch ohne
kontroversen ohne streit
es hat weder zwischen den bundesländern
noch zwischen den bundesländern und der
bundesebene hier ein streit gegeben in
der sache sondern sowie die
bundeskanzlerin sagt wir waren uns sehr
einig natürlich auch in der bewertung
der ausgangslage und insofern war auch
sehr schnell klar dass wir hier einen
gemeinsamen handlungsdruck haben den wir
auch aufnehmen wollen
letztendlich dauert es dann eben doch
immer viele stunden weil es natürlich
die gelegenheit ist auch im rahmen der
ministerpräsident der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz dinge auch
mal grundsätzlich zu diskutieren und
erfahrungen der eigenen bundesländer
nebeneinander zu legen und es dauert
auch deswegen mitunter länger weil an
denen 34 punkten von den zwanzig seiten
wo wir dann tatsächlich auch
unterschiedliche positionen ausgetragen
haben es tatsächlich auch um viel ging
das muss man eben auch sehen
ich möchte für mich noch mal festhalten
was mich besonders bewegt in der
situation in der wir sind wir arbeiten
wir jeden tag und sehr
selbstverständlich inzwischen mit den
incident zahlen und die zahlen gehen
hoch und runter und wir vergleichen sie
zwischen den bundesländern
und manchmal habe ich selbst das gefühl
dass wir das sehr anonym sehr abstrakt
diskutieren diese zahlen aber immer
wieder wird mir sehr bewusst und sehr
deutlich worum es eigentlich geht wenn
ich vivantes oder charité in meiner
stadt besucher und das will ich hier
nochmal ganz klar sagen wir sind jetzt
in berlin in einer situation wo wir ein
viertel der berliner intensivbetten
nutzen für die patienten und wo es wo
wir eine situation haben dass nahezu
jeder und jede in diesen intensivbetten
beatmet werden muss und wir haben die
situation dass wir in berlin mit unter
tage haben mit 20 30 verstorbenen und
das wiederum auf die bundesebene
umgerechnet bedeutet tage wo ihr
bundesweit 200 oder 300 verstorbene
haben wenn wir das zusammen diskutieren
würden in zusammenhang mit unfällen oder
unglücken würden wir jeden tag dazu auch
eine andere berichterstattung haben und
würden uns ganz anders glaube ich auch
mit diesen zahlen auseinandersetzen
mir jedenfalls wird das immer wieder
dann sehr bewusst wenn man sich diese
zahlen so veranschaulicht wie hier
wirklich die situation ist und dass man
dem er überhaupt nicht gleichgültig
begegnen kann sondern dass es
selbstverständlich ist darauf wirklich
mit allen möglichkeiten die man zur
verfügung hat auch zu reagieren weil
dahinter verbergen sich hinter jeder
einzelnen zahlen
menschliche schicksale und menschliche
tragödien das ist der rahmen in dem wir
uns hier bewegen und wir haben vor
diesem hintergrund tatsächlich auch das
erreicht was uns wichtig war es wird das
letzte mal zusammengekommen
sind dass wir in einem papier einen
längerfristigen weg miteinander
formulieren wie wir jetzt in den
nächsten wochen miteinander umgehen
wollen was wir erreichen wollen mit
welchen maßnahmen und wir haben eben
auch die unterschiedlichsten aspekte
aufgegriffen auch das war uns wichtig
und wir konnten da tatsächlich große
schritte vorankommen
wir haben konkret reagiert nochmal und
maßnahmen die wir bisher schon
beschlossen haben die auch etwas
gebracht haben aber eben noch nicht
genug wir haben diese maßnahmen
verlängert wir haben darüber hinaus
weitere einschränkungen und maßnahmen
beschlossen auch für den dezember
wir haben allerdings auch und das ist
eine neue qualität in beide richtung
formuliert wie länder agieren können
wenn sich die infektions dynamik in die
eine oder andere richtung bewegt länder
die sehr gute sehr niedrige zahlen haben
haben jetzt auch die möglichkeit schon
agieren zu können auch im sinne von
erleichterungen und wieder ein stück
weit normalität auch wieder darstellen
das wird auch nicht einfach sein das ist
kein selbstläufer und selbst die die
niedrige zahlen haben haben eigentlich
immer noch zu hohe weil wir ja
bundesweit noch ganz andere ziele
anstreben aber sie stehen besser da als
andere länder und bekommen ein stückweit
möglichkeit auch wieder etwas zu
ermöglichen andere länder
die bundeskanzlerin hat das angesprochen
mit sehr hohen infektionszahlen mit
einer starken infektions dynamik müssen
noch mehr machen als das was in den
papieren festgehalten ist müssen sich
mindestens damit auseinandersetzen wie
können sie noch mehr möglichkeiten
nutzen um zu besseren zahlen zu kommen
wir haben den einzelhandel aufgegriffen
wir haben das thema schule aufgegriffen
wir haben wirtschaftspolitik
aufgegriffen
wir haben natürlich uns der besonderen
situation mit weihnachten mitgehen
das nennt es jetzt mal mit den fest- und
feiertagen insgesamt weihnachten und
silvester auseinandergesetzt
also insofern ist tatsächlich das doch
mal in einem größeren raum formuliert
worden wie in dem wir uns bewegen mit
welchen schritten wir jetzt was
erreichen wollen
und noch einmal es gibt dazu wirklich
eine große bundes
weiter verständigung wir werden uns
weiter austauschen sie überhaupt keine
frage auch wenn wir jetzt einen 20
seiten papier haben für die nächsten
wochen ist es eine
selbstverständlichkeit dass wir immer
wieder auch die situation bewerten auf
den unterschiedlichsten ebenen unsere
erfahrungen unsere zahlen unsere erfolge
nebeneinander legen und sehen wo wir
gegebenenfalls auch wieder dinge zu
lassen können oder wo wir gegebenenfalls
auch erneut erneut oder weiter
eingreifen müssen
also das ist etwas was uns natürlich ja
auch eins und wir sehen die situation
und die möchte mich da auch dem appell
an schließen dass wir natürlich in
anbetracht dieser besonderen jahreszeit
auch einiges ermöglichen wollen was
vielleicht noch nicht geboten wäre wenn
man sich ganz kühl die zahlen anguckt
aber dinge zu ermöglichen heißt ja nicht
dass alles genutzt werden muss was
möglich ist und insofern ist das nach
wie vor auch mein dringender appell sich
das bewusst zu machen ist sich bewusst
zu machen was jeder und jede einzelne
nach wie vor tun kann um andere auch zu
schützen und familienfeste so wie in den
früheren jahren selbst wenn sie jetzt
möglich sind so wie wir das festgehalten
haben muss man vielleicht auch nicht so
groß und in der form organisieren wie
man es in den letzten jahren getan hat
dass wir sind einfach in einer situation
ich habe das eingangs beschrieben wo es
wirklich
man muss es immer wieder so sagen auch
in vielen bereichen um leben und tod
geht
es geht darum wie wir menschen besser
schützen können wir haben große schritte
nach vorne gemacht im bereich der
testungen und des impfstoffs aber es ist
noch nicht so dass wir damit in den
nächsten tagen so rechnen können dass
das zu einer entlastung führt und
insofern müssen unsere regeln und müssen
unsere maßnahmen weiter bestandteil
dieser fürsorge für einander seien in
diesem umfeld bewegen wir uns und ich
glaube wir haben auf dieser grundlage
tatsächlich heute viel positives
miteinander verabreden können wohl
wissend dass auch noch viel zu tun ist
herr ministerpräsident sie haben eine
sehr viel damit werden den bonus konzern
die lage bleibt sehr sehr ernst wir
haben ein teilerfolg erzielt wir haben
den die große exponentielle wachstum
gebrochen ja das positiv aber der erfolg
war nicht so groß wie erhofft
warum bei der lok tor natürlich milder
ist als woanders und deutlich milder als
wir im frühjahr hatten im frühjahr sind
wir damit deutlich andere locker und hat
mit schnell wirkenden maßnahmen wir
sehen unsere um länder wie frankreich
oder belgien sehr hart in london
einsteigen mit schnelleren erfolgen das
heißt es muss eben klar sein
der bewusste entscheidung weniger
gesellschaftliche folgen jetzt so haben
bedeutet eine längere zeit die wir an
geduld war das erste daraus folgt aber
zweitens dass die gefahr nicht vorbei
ist
die bundeskanzlerin hat auch
bürgermeister müller hat angesprochen
die probleme die jetzt da sind die
infektionszahlen scheinen stabil nach
oben aber keiner darf sich täuschen
das sind die höchste zahl an infizierten
und erkrankten menschen über hier in
deutschland noch nie waren so viele
menschen in deutschland erkrankt wie
derzeit die todesfälle wachsen wenn man
sich überlegt wenn wir nichts tun würden
und allein das level von jetzt behalten
ich habe mir jeden tag sieht man jeden
tag 200 verstorben
das sind dann bis weihnachten um die 600
606.000 schon 6000 menschen die nicht
weihnachten erleben
und da geht es nicht um die statistische
zahlen zum schicksal am familien
menschen die vielleicht lange hätten
leben können und die wegen corona jetzt
sterben und ich kann es interessant ist
empörend wie nonchalance über das thema
geredet wird es keine statistik das muss
uns alle als hauptaufgabe umtreiben
nicht nur die überlastung des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern sondern
leben zu schützen wollen wir könnten es
schützen wenn wir noch stärker
miteinander auch vorsicht setzen
deswegen ist es wichtig den müden
lockdown zu verlängern und zu vertiefen
beides zusammen
nicht nur einfach zu verlängern sondern
auch zu vertiefen verbunden mit appellen
jahr vorsicht umsicht walten zu lassen
jeder kann helfen wirklich jeder aber
zur appelle kommen auch die regel
es ist so dass es jetzt kein düster des
bildes wird sein es gibt die hoffnung
die zulassung der impfstoffe die
beschleunigung der impfstoff ideen ist
tatsächlich ein ansatz der hoffnung
nur keiner darauf glauben wenn ihm
stoffe da sind und geimpft werden kann
dass innerhalb von einem tagen und
wochen mit problem beseitigt ist der
impfstoff hilft er ist aber keinen
zaubertrank und er befreit nicht einfach
von der vorsicht und umsicht die wir
brauchen verlängern bis ende dezember ja
eindeutig danke übrigens an der stelle
auch mal den bund für die hilfe die
geleistet wird nirgendwo in europa wird
eine solche hilfe geleistet wie in
deutschland für die betroffenen branchen
und in ländern geht es dabei gut was sie
zahlen gar nix da weiß zahlt alles der
bund ab das muss an der stelle einmal
vermerkt werden dass das auto nicht
leicht ist für die abgeordneten für den
bund unglaubliche summen aufzuwenden
sind am ende jetzt fast 30 grad nur
dafür
man stelle sich vor was man für das geld
sonst hätte er machen können also
dankeschön dafür für diese unterstützung
die da jetzt geleistet wird und
verschärfen dort insbesondere wo wir
feststellen dass wir in der fläche
verbesserung brauchen aber auch bei den
hot spots die hotspots sind tatsächlich
auch das problem nicht der gesamtindex
allein sondern die hotspots wie die
entwicklung sehr schnell nach oben ab
geht und dafür braucht es regeln braucht
es einschränkungen braucht es
verbesserungen
das haben definiert bei den kontakten
und es ist auch das thema schule ich
will das ausdrücklich nochmal ansprechen
infektionsgeschehen an der schule
kontakte zu reduzieren wir haben
umfassend diskutiert das ist an einigen
stellen mir noch nicht ganz so klar
genug aber jedes land wird es dann
entsprechend wahrnehmen
wir haben uns da auch gegenseitig
verständlich darüber für mich ist auch
ganz klar dass hybrid und wechsel
unterricht dann eben ab einer bestimmten
jahrgangsstufe nach dem fehler und der
leopoldina ein sehr wirksames instrument
ist nun auf der einen seite das
infektionsgeschehen zu reduzieren aber
auch auf der anderen seite die
gesamtsituation des schutzraumes schule
zu steigen sie mich auch
und wir handeln immer nur ausschließlich
zum wohle der schülerinnen und schüler
dann will ich das auch sagen darf von
all den gruppen die ich erlebe in diesem
land gehen am gelassensten die jungen
leute und auch die schüler und schüler
mit dieser herausforderung
mein ganz persönliches kompliment an
alle dass wenn es sich so viele
zuschauer noch mit dem ergebnis aber mal
sagen das ist ziemlich großartig was da
geleistet wird wir haben in bayern eine
maske an der grundschule die kleinen
kommen raus haben überhaupt kein problem
die einsamen den eltern reisen in die
maske aussagen runter also das sind die
die kinder und jugendlichen die in
dieser pandemie es auch wirklich
hoffnung auch zum teil geben weil es
optimal hieß die sind schuld das
gegenteil so also wir haben jetzt klare
regeln bis zu weihnachten
weihnachten ist das fest der familie sie
lässt er mir das feste freundin wenn man
das so sagen darf dafür gibt es
ausnahmen was aber nicht heißt dass es
jetzt grenzenlose auseinander es geht
nicht darum silvester oder weihnachten
die große party zu feiern sondern
vielleicht auch an weihnachten einmal
den wert von familie zu schätzen alle
reden von familie
ich finde dieses jahr sollte man das
wirklich auch an der stelle machen und
bei silvester geht es ihm einfach dumm
auch im engsten kreis zu feiern und
nicht die große party die große
menschenansammlungen zu wählen
auch da gibt es die bereiche
einschränken dann letztes ich glaube wir
haben jetzt ein gutes regelwerk
vereinbart
es trägt uns auch ganz sicherlich gut
bis zu den ferien die ferien dürfen aber
nicht wieder ein rückschlag werden ist
mir ein ganz wichtiges ganz wichtiger
punkt
es war bislang meistens so dass die
fähre in deutschland rückschlag
faschingsfan letztes jahr war der
aufgalopp die sommerferien sind wir ganz
ehrlich war nicht so optimal gestaltet
am ende die wissens gedacht hat wir
haben im september leider zu früh im
jahr wieder zu hohe zahlen
deswegen spielen die ferien eine große
rolle deswegen ist reisetätigkeit in
diesem jahr
bitte entsprechend zu unterlassen bzw
nur für familienfeiern zu machen oder
familienbesuche und deswegen gesagt dass
mit dem skifahren aber wichtig uns gibt
es da nicht um die spaß und die freude
am skifahren zu vergeben
bayern ist zum beispiel ein großes
skifahrer land
aber wir machen uns einfach sorge was
österreich betrifft ich habe gerade
heute abend ganz spannende kommentaren
verschiedenen zeitung gelesen
die sich sehr kritisch damit
auseinandersetzen sogar der erste
präsident in österreich sehr
zurückhaltend sagt achtung da könnten
risiken entstehen ich kann mir einfach
massenhafte skilifte und an der gondel
stehen anstehen und und skihütte und
ähnliches mehr und abgeschickt kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen
dank der bund dass er damit hessen.de
von ansonsten wenn es nicht glauben
sollte muss man sich selber noch mal
überlegen
auch was das bedeutet sind ja alles
reisen in risikogebiete mit
entsprechendem ausland trotzdem nochmal
die ferien sollen dann am ende kleinen
risiko bilden
und wenn wir dann im januar wieder
zurück staaten oder start in das neue
jahr
dann sollten sie auch das level dass wir
gemeinsam aus vor sorgerecht erhalten
können
deswegen nochmals sehr lange muss man
ehrlicherweise zusammen es war auch sehr
detailliert und ediert und es war noch
eine auszeit notwendig aber am ende ist
es dann gut wenn das ergebnis stimmt und
jetzt darf ich kann man sagen da zeigt
sich deutschland insgesamt
handlungsfähig dann kommen wir zu ihren
fragen seien sie bitte fair gegenüber
ihren kollegen stellen sie bitte nur
eine jeweils herr blank dpa beginnt frau
bundeskanzlerin immer wieder ist der
bereich schule stein des anstoßes und
der diskussions notwendigkeit herr
müller hat heute gesprochen von
grundsätzlichem über das gesprochen
werden müsste
können sie uns erklären wo denn der
grundlegende unterschied ist zwischen
dem ansatz des kanzleramts und der
länder die länder werfen wer zum teil
dem kanzleramt vor
es sei zu abstrakt dabei und sind die
länder da näher dran dunking
die länder sind sicherlich zuständig
aber wir haben eine gemeinsame
grundeinstellung wir wollen schulen
offen halten und kitas geben genauso und
zu diesem zu dieser grundhaltung stehen
wir auch alle und jetzt geht es um die
frage dass ganz offensichtlich die
kleineren kinder nicht so eine hohe
infektiosität aufweisen das scheint sich
jetzt immer mehr herauszustellen
deshalb sind grundschulen auch gar
keinen gegenstand der diskussion gewesen
genauso wenig die kitas aber je näher
die jungen menschen ans erwachsensein
kommen das leuchtet ja auch ein um so
ähnlich verhalten sich entsprechend
wachsen
auch was ihre infektiosität
angelangt und das sind kontakte in der
schule und wir sagen normalerweise man
soll alles daran setzen dass die regeln
eingehalten werden können also abstand
maske und dann auch stand maske und eins
fehlten er gerade nach den vielen
stunden also wir jetzt schon wissen für
jene regel ja genau
und da haben wir dann die frage was
macht man wenn die kinder sitzen jahre
die jugendlichen relativ lange zusammen
eine normale mund nasen schutz ist ja
kein hundertprozentiger schutz das
wissen wir alle
dazu brauchen ein effect 2 oder ffp drei
masken und deshalb war die diskussion
kann man dann wenn es so sehr hohe
incidents raten gibt muss man dann
zusätzliche maßnahmen machen raten uns
rk ii und leopoldina dazu und so haben
wir es jetzt auch gemacht dass dann
solche maßnahmen ins auge gefasst werden
wie hybrid oder wechseln unterricht um
die mindestabstände besser einzuhalten
und auch um den transport zur schule
natürlich auszudünnen denn wenn weniger
kinder in die schule geht habe ich auch
die in gedränge beim transport wir haben
auch über die schulbusse gesprochen und
dass wir immer das geht auch hier
zusätzliche busse bereitgestellt werden
damit nicht so viele kontakte sind so
und ich glaube das hat dann zu einem
ergebnis geführt jeder weiß dass diese
umorganisation in den schulen nicht ganz
einfach sind aber mir war das schon sehr
wichtig dass wir auch an dieser stelle
ein zeichen setzen und deutlich machen
dass bei den älteren da doch
handlungsbedarf besteht aus meiner sicht
frau hat er öfter der letzten frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben weihnachten
gesagt das sei für die christen und für
die familien insgesamt wichtig und herr
ministerpräsident sie haben gesagt dass
er das fest der familie und silvester
dann er das fest der freunde und die
frage die ich an sie herr sodann habe
ist riskieren sie damit nicht die
akzeptanz bei denjenigen für die dieses
fest das weihnachtsfest nicht die
zuschreibung hat die sie damit treffen
oder sage ich
auch die das bild was sie da entwerfen
weil wenn der gesellschaft leben wo
manche nicht christen sind wo wir fast
18 millionen single haushalte haben drei
millionen alleinerziehende die
möglicherweise ein völlig anderes
familien und mähren freundschafts bild
haben danke ich wunderbar jetzt hier
essen habe ich das wort christlich gar
nicht erwähnt und ich habe es bewusst
als fester familie genommen und familie
haben wir alle und familie bedeutet wird
es nicht nur mit zehn personen familie
ist wie sie sagen eine familie die
alleinerziehende ist eine
patchworkfamilie familie sind zwei
menschen die zusammen leben verbindet
sind die zusammenkommen eltern
großeltern kinder und insofern sicht ist
genau anders das was wir hier machen
schließt genau das ein
es ist glaube ich eine sehr empathische
balance die wehren der schule treffen wo
wir haben lange darüber geredet ob man
bei silvester und weihnachten zeit
aktien nicht anders definieren soll
wir haben sie bewusst so gemacht und am
ende entschieden war alles andere auch
mit lebens real gewesen wir wollten uns
nichts treffen man maßnahmen die zwar
gut klingen aber die nicht durchgeführt
werden können wir hatten am letzten
woche dass eine debatte um die
empfehlung gewährten die nicht so nicht
so alle überzeugt hat das wollen wir
diesmal anders machen ich glaube das tun
wir und wir nämlich alle mit und mein
eindruck ist familien haben alle und ich
finde es wirklich schön wenn dieses jahr
an weihnachten alle die dieses fest der
familie im vordergrund setzen eben nicht
in erster linie an den konsum und den
wert von weihnachten materiell denken
sondern man diesen zusammenhalt der
gesellschaft der familie also ich finde
wir schließen sie genau ein und umarmen
er mit unser vorschlag als dass wir aus
ganzen also ich habe das wort christen
in den mund genommen und das weihnachten
sein original oder seinen ursprung darin
hat dass die christen jesus gebot feiern
das ist ja unstrittig
wir haben eine unseren formulierung aber
ganz eindeutig gesagt man soll es im
engsten familien und freundeskreis
beginn und das schließt jeden ein egal
welchen glaubens welcher religion
welcher herkunft er ist unter sie ist
und ich glaube das ist richtig so und
das eröffnet auch für jeden spielraum
herr busacca
vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin herr
söder herr müller wir haben jetzt bisher
wenig über silvester gesprochen
ziel der übung eigentlich aller
maßnahmen seit märz sind ja die
krankenhäuser möglichst am laufen zu
halten damit sie eben nicht überlaufen
jetzt wäre silvester eine möglichkeit
gewesen zu sagen böllern verbieten wir
wir verbieten komplett den verkauf von
feuerwerk und entlasten damit in der
neujahrsnacht die krankenhäuser warum
ist es zu diesem beschluss nicht
bekommen
ja also wir haben uns klar entschieden
dass wir nicht der festen überzeugung
sind dass raketen und böller per se eine
pandemische herausforderung sind nur
dort wo die menschenansammlung
zusammenkommen ist es auch wichtig ein
großer see bester film ich verbringe
immer silvester innen drin weil ich
meistens bei unten bin die sich da
heraus gefordert für den film das wunder
schlimm
ich war immer bei den unten also ich bin
keiner kann man nicht vorstellen dann
mit versetztem eine rakete gezündet
hätte vielleicht politisch aber
jedenfalls nicht so was also ich bin da
relativ in der frage klar aber wir haben
winfried kretschmann hat uns einmal an
der runde gesagt man sollte nicht etwas
machen da wo man jetzt ein anderes
politisches ziel verfolgt es eigentlich
nichts mit dieser herausforderung zu tun
hat das hat mich persönlich und viele
andere am ende überzeugt wir wollen kein
generelles böllerverbot sondern dort wo
es ihm zu dieser herausforderung führt
in den entsprechend großen straßenzügen
oder an plätzen wo sich die menschen
versammelt da haben wir ein klares
signal gesetzt das finde ich auch
richtig
alles andere übrigens muss man dann an
anderer stelle entscheidendes tun
übrigens auch viele kommunen es gibt ja
schon welche die generell des bella
nicht mehr wollen
das liegt dann bei den kommunen ja es
gab ja dazu auch den den vorschlag dass
eventuell ganz zu verbieten aber so wie
er selber sagt aus gutem grund haben wir
uns dann auch bundesweit eben auf einen
anderen weg verständigt das heißt ja
nicht dass man nicht selbst auch noch
mal mehr machen kann
wir haben in berlin ohnehin schon ich
glaube jetzt seit zwei jahren die
situation dass wir einen eigenen platz
und straßenzügen dieses böller verbot
ausgesprochen haben und mit sicherheit
werden wir im senat auch darüber beraten
wie wir das ausweiten können und genau
mit dem gedanken nicht grundsätzlich
feuerwerk könnte man aus
umweltpolitischen gesichtspunkten auch
diskutieren nicht grundsätzlich
feuerwerk zu verbieten sondern genau das
was wir im moment vermeiden wollen
gruppenbildung dass menschen sich
zusammen stellen zusammen feiern
überstunden zusammenstehen und zu
vielleicht sogar auch zusammen trinken
und feiern
dass wir genau das vermeiden wollen weil
daraus eben auch die infektionsgefahren
entstehen
und insofern ja sage ich ganz offen so
spielt das aus wester eine rolle wir
wollen da nicht zusätzliche
attraktivität schaffen wir haben oft
formuliert das natürlich auch öffentlich
veranstaltete feuerwerke gar nicht
stattfinden dürfen
wo also im rahmen von irgendwelchen
einladungen dann noch gezielt gesagt
wird kommt doch extra damit wir zusammen
feuerwerk machen können also dieser
gedanke ist schon glaube ich ganz gut
formuliert er lässt dann immer noch den
spielraum dass jeder der nun ein
einfamilienhaus hat mit dem garten auch
mal drei raketen steigen lassen kann
aber wir wollen ihm auf den belebten
plätzen und straßen gruppenbildung
vermeiden und deswegen machen wir das an
dieser stelle tatsächlich auch
unattraktiv und schränken es ein stück
letzte frage rinke von voltas frau
wollen das kannst du an letzte woche
waren sie ja eher unzufrieden oder
hatten gesagt dass sie sich mehr
maßnahme hätten vorstellen können
ich würd sich deswegen jetzt noch mal
fragen sind sie wirklich überzeugt dass
das das nötige set an maßnahmen ist um
die inzidenz von 50 die sie als zielwert
ausgegeben haben zu erreichen und an
welchem zeitpunkt sollen diese 50
eigentlich erreicht sein jetzt ende des
jahres oder was haben sie dafür eine
zielvorstellung
das wäre das schönste aber ich bin da
möchte ich keine zusage machen wir haben
eben jetzt diese zeit in der wir auch
seinen lockerungen
erlauben von 23 bis zum ersten januar
wir sind sehr sehr davon abhängig dass
die bürgerinnen und bürger auch weiter
vernünftig sind solidarisch sind und
mitmachen denn die kontakte sind es es
war für uns auch schon im oktober schwer
zu sagen was sind 75% kontakt
reduzierung heute wissen wir es waren
nur 40 und es muss mehr dazu kommen wir
haben an einigen stellen jetzt nochmal
verschärfungen gemacht ich bin zufrieden
dass wir was zu den schulen gesagt haben
ich bin zufrieden dass wir bei der
einkaufsflächen in den großen einkaufs
malls da auch eine beschränkung der
personenzahl gemacht hat ich glaube die
kontakt beschränkungen wie wir sie jetzt
bis zum 20 23
dezember haben ist sicherlich
realistischer als das was wir letzte
woche damen ins auge gefasst haben das
hat ja auch sag jetzt mal zu recht im
kritik geführt
und dann müssen wir sehen ich kann das
nicht versprechen
wir konnten es im für den november nicht
versprechen aber wir haben jetzt schon
gesehen wie mühselig doch das ist die
infektionsquelle unterzubringen
wir sind froh dass es ein plateau ist
aber mehr ist es eben auch noch nicht
und es ist überhaupt kein signal der
entwarnung zu geben sondern im gegenteil
und dass wir immerhin 62 landkreise plus
berlin haben die doch eine sehr wohl
incidents rate haben zeigt ja auch dass
man da noch mal schärfer angehen muss
das passt freut mich dass wir das getan
haben und ich hoffe dass nutzen und
setzen jetzt auch alle um
dankeschön morgen früh im deutschen
bundestag
ja soweit die pressekonferenz nach dem
corona gipfel nach dem bund länder
corona gipfel die pressekonferenz mit
der kanzlerin dem regierenden
bürgermeister von berlin müller und dem
csu ministerpräsidenten aus bayern söder
wir wollen diese ergebnisse das was
gesagt worden ist und die neuen
maßnahmen einordnen mit der leiterin
unseres hauptstadtstudios in berlin
gunther love energy star grundlage wir
müssen erst mal sagen seit 2 uhr hat man
da gesessen und beraten das ist ja
unglaublich mehr als fünfeinhalb stunden
wie ist das ganze zu erklären vor allem
weil er die ministerpräsidenten mit
einer beschlussvorlage reingegangen sind
und die sich nicht so sehr unterschieden
hat von der des kanzleramtes ja das ist
wirklich überraschend wir haben uns
natürlich diese verschiedenen vorlagen
die es in den letzten tagen gegeben hat
angeschaut und im vergleich zur letzten
woche sah das nach großer einigkeit aus
und nach einigen wenigen punkten die da
noch diskutiert werden müssten außerdem
muss man ja auch in erinnerung haben
dass die länder letzte woche quasi
gesagt haben naja wenn es besser
vorbereitet gewesen wäre dann hätten wir
uns auch einigen können er wurde ja die
ganze diskussion und deshalb verschoben
weil sie gesagt haben das nehmen wir
jetzt mal in die hand und dann machen
wir es ordentlich so klang das zumindest
durch und jetzt hat sich eben gezeigt
das ist es nicht gewesen der grund waren
nicht die schlechte vorbereitung sondern
wenn ich das jetzt mal interpretiere aus
der pressekonferenz heraus der grund
liegt schon viel tiefer wir haben gerade
eben den regierenden bürgermeister von
berlin michael müller gehört der gesagt
hat na ja da waren dann drei vier dinge
die wir doch noch mal sehr grundsätzlich
diskutieren mussten und man hat glaube
ich auch am verhalten und an den minen
der drei teilnehmer dieser
pressekonferenz gesehen das war eine
harte auseinandersetzung deutlich härter
als alle sie miteinander eben erwartet
hatten
die kanzlerin hat es gesagt es war eine
intensive diskussion
wenn man so ein bisschen die politik
verfolgt dann weiß man diplomatisch
übersetzt heißt das es hat ordentlich
gekracht und es gab richtig streit was
waren denn die hauptknackpunkt geben
also wir was wir gehört haben während
dieser veranstaltung und man muss dazu
sagen dass war gegen ende der
veranstaltung erstaunlich wenig also
selbst sehr erfahrene kollegen die hier
quasi immer das gras wachsen hören
bekamen relativ wenig informationen aus
dieser runde aber es hat wohl vor allem
beim thema schulen gehakt
es hat bei jetzt muss ich mal kurz auf
meinem zettel gucken weil wir haben so
viele entwicklungen gehabt beim thema
hotspots also maßnahmen für besonders
betroffene bereiche für bereiche für
regionen und landkreise mit besonders
hohen zahlen und auch beim thema
silvester gesprächsbedarf gegeben aber
ich will nicht ausschließen dass es noch
weitere punkte gab aber diese drei sind
mindestens punkte gewesen über die sehr
lange diskutiert worden ist bei den
schulen hätte man jetzt denken können
die länder kommen mit einem fertigen
konzept das haben sie ja angekündigt und
dann wird vielleicht noch mal über das
eine oder andere gesprochen das war
nicht so bei silvester gab es eben die
frage soll auch silvester ausgenommen
werden von den einschränkungen genau wie
zum beispiel weihnachten und bei den hot
spots da haben wir heute erlebt dass
noch eine ganz neue kategorie erfunden
worden ist bisher gab es ja die
einteilung in die bereiche in denen es
35 neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
innerhalb von sieben tagen gibt und dann
die bereiche in denen es 50
neuinfektionen in diesem zeitraum und
bei dieser einwohnerzahl gibt und jetzt
gibt es eine neue zahl die heißt 200
neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner in
sieben tagen und das müssen wir uns dann
noch mal ganz genau angucken denn es
gibt auch schon widersprüchliche
aussagen wie das ganze zu verstehen ist
ob es dann automatisch zu weiteren
verschärften maßnahmen kommt das würde
berlin betreffen und 62 weitere
landkreise haben wir gerade eben gehört
oder ob es keinen automatismus gibt das
hat der hessische ministerpräsident
bouffier gerade eben auf einer
pressekonferenz gesagt also man sieht es
gibt die bemühungen um neue maßnahmen es
gibt auch die bemühung die zahlen noch
mal deutlich runter zu bringen die
infektionszahlen aber ich glaube ein
ganz wichtiger und zentraler punkt heute
ist dass wir uns verabschieden sollten
von der vorstellung dass es zur
bundeseinheitlichen maßnahmen kommt denn
das ist für mich jetzt nach dieser
pressekonferenz das wirklich neue bund
und länder scheint einen strich drunter
gezogen zu haben sie haben in beide
richtungen geöffnet sie sagen auf der
einen seite bundesländer und regionen
die wenige infektionen haben können mehr
lockern und die regionen und landkreise
in denen es besonders schlimm ist die
müssen aber auch mehr tun und das ist
eben nicht halten keine einheitlichkeit
das war ja eigentlich so ein bisschen
das ziel einheitlicher aufzutreten
sozusagen einigung zu schaffen
aber das hat nicht ganz vielleicht
funktioniert doch sehr viel streit hat
es gegeben vielen dank für die
einschätzung in chuck und sarah banerjee
vielen dank nach berlin
ja es haben mehrere die kanzlerin angela
merkel söder haben es gesagt die lage
ist ernst und ausgerechnet heute gab es
diese schockierende zahl 4 110 tote in
zusammenhang mit 19
das ist ein absoluter neuer trauriger
rekord und insofern stellt sich die
frage wie sind diese maßnahmen zu
bewerten auch aus medizinischer sicht
kann man wirklich an der lage an der
sehr ernsten lage etwas ändern deshalb
wollen wir sprechen und das ganze ein
orten mit der biologin an der
universitätsklinik leipzig corinna
pietsch ich begrüße sie ganz herzlich
sie haben die pressekonferenz verfolgt
müssen wir einfach mal fragen was sagt
die virologin kann man damit zufrieden
sein
nützen diese nasen maßnahmen etwas ja
schönen guten abend zunächst also ich
habe die pressekonferenz verfolgt ich
bin vielleicht noch nicht bis ins letzte
schlau draus geworden was das jetzt
tatsächlich in einzelnen bedeutet für
die einzelnen regionen
denn so wie eben auch nochmal dargelegt
sind wir in der situation dass es doch
offensichtlich wieder viel auf länder
ebene erst dann endgültig geklärt werden
wird was sicherlich gut ist ist die
ausweitung der masken pflicht ich gehört
habe
sowohl an schulen aber auch auf
öffentlichen plätzen parkplätzen in
fußgängerzonen soweit ich das verstanden
habe auch an arbeits und betriebsstätten
das wird sicherlich eine maßnahme sein
die dazu führen kann dass wir weniger
infektionen sehen auch wenn wir
es tatsächlich umgesetzt bekommen dass
ich im privaten weniger personen
gleichzeitig treffen
doch das wird sicherlich eine große
hilfe sein ich hoffe wir kriegen das so
umgesetzt insgesamt ist es natürlich
sinnvoll
das ist ja eigentlich das was am
klarsten wurde dass die maßnahmen
überhaupt nicht gelockert werden sondern
weitere wochen fortgesetzt werden müssen
und das ist aus meiner sicht das was am
meisten jetzt tatsächlich dann auch
helfen wird dann wollen wir einfach mal
eine frage aufgreifen die thomas
eichenhofer über facebook uns
geschrieben hat wenn man schon so harte
maßnahmen ergreift wieso lockert man
dann zwischen weihnachten und silvester
ja wenn man doch dann vielleicht
erwarten kann dass die gesunkenen zahlen
dann möglicherweise wieder nach oben
schnell
was sagen sie jetzt als virologin dazu
dass man eben ja so ein zeichen macht um
weihnachten und silvester herum und sagt
ach da ist doch einiges wieder locker
weil ja eben weihnachten ist was sagen
sie aus theologischer sich dazu der
absolvierung macht ja nicht unbedingt
sozusagen ferien an weihnachten
nein das wird leider keine ferien machen
an weihnachten
das lässt sich natürlich virologisch
epidemiologisch gar nicht begründen
warum man das macht das sind rein
emotional politische entscheidungen die
da tatsächlich getroffen werden
sicherlich auch in hinblick dessen was
man meint auch was umsetzbar ist und was
auch akzeptanz findet also das ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht biologisch zu
begründen dort lockerungen zu machen
letzte frage sie haben schon gesagt dass
so manche regeln und wenn wir von regeln
sagen dann sind sie richtig vorschriften
das masken eventuell ein in der
innenstadt mal getragen werden müssen wo
es eng ist vielleicht in fußgängerzonen
vor einem geschäft das das ganze doch
gut ist wenn man sich sozusagen die
beschlüsse hier anschaut die 20 seiten
dann sind ja doch sehr viele appelle und
empfehlungen ja auch drin und wir haben
sie an der pressekonferenz ja auch immer
wieder gehört wir appellieren an die
menschen man muss es auch nicht
ausreizen etc
glauben sie dass das ausreicht sozusagen
doch diese vielen appelle und das ganze
offen lassen
ich glaube es kann dann was bringen wenn
wir alle miteinander begreifen wie einst
doch die situation ist und stand diese
appelle als hilfestellung für uns nehmen
was dennoch unsererseits möglich ist was
wir umsetzen können
ich habe es auch so gehört sehr viele
möglichkeiten und appelle wurden benannt
es waren weniger tatsächlich
verordnungen im raum und ich habe auch
wahrgenommen dass an manchen stellen
eben darüber gesprochen wurde er dinge
die vielleicht lockerung entsprochen
hätten einzugrenzen das in richtung
gesagt zu den möglichkeiten ja wie gehen
wir um mit dem silvesterfeuerwerk wie
gehen wir um mit skiurlaub das sind ja
dinge die wir in den letzten wochen auch
nicht hatten sondern das wäre ja quasi
noch eher ein zusätzlicher grund für das
virus sich auszubreiten
von daher bin ich so ein bisschen
skeptisch ob die jetzt vorgestellten
maßnahmen tatsächlich ausreichen jetzt
war ein punkt ja da hat man anscheinend
stunden verhandelt gestritten gerungen
das thema eben schule wenn man die
beschlüsse die beschlussvorlagen einfach
mal vergleicht die der
ministerpräsidenten und die das
kanzleramt heute sozusagen ins rennen
geschickt hat dann sind sie ja gar nicht
so groß und unterschiedlich gewesen das
thema aber wenn es in der
pressekonferenz ja auch gehört ist zum
beispiel masken pflicht die soll jetzt
ab höheren jahrgangsstufen ab klasse 7
sozusagen eingeführt werden dass die
schülerinnen und schüler eben auch im
unterricht eine maske tragen
jetzt haben sie ja auch gehört dass
ministerpräsident söder sagt na ja in
bayern das machen auch die grundschüler
das hätte er sich das gewünscht das
kanzleramt auch was sagen sie denn dazu
masken pflicht erst ab klasse 7 das
virus betritt also keine schulklasse
fünf oder sechs wie sehen sie das
biologisch gesehen sind wir natürlich
dafür eine masken pflicht auch für die
niedrigeren klassen für die fünfte
sechste klasse aber vielleicht auch
sogar für die grundschule einzuführen
wann immer dies irgendwie möglich ist
also alles was möglich ist sollte man
denke ich tun
ich persönlich finde
durchaus machbar und ich finde es auch
zumutbar für kleine kinder also kleinere
schüler auch maske zu tragen ich denke
dass man das eigentlich auch ganz gut
vermitteln kann wir hören immer wieder
kinder brauchten normalität das ist
sicherlich so aber ich glaube kinder
sind auch hellwach und sehen in welcher
normalität die derzeit leben und die
normalität ist dass wir in der korona
pandemie sind dass erwachsene überall
maske tragen und ich denke das lässt
sich eigentlich kindern auch recht gut
vermitteln
dann bleiben wir beim thema schule was
sagen sie zu wechsel unterricht hybrid
unterricht da gab es ja mal vorletzte
woche doch den sehr klaren strengen
strikten vorschlag aus dem kanzleramt
wechsel unterricht hybrid unterricht
unbedingt da haben sich die länder
letzte woche stark gegen gewehrt jetzt
ist für der vorsichtige kompromiss dass
er daneben kommen könnte wenn der
institute über 200 ist also wenn die
lage ganz ganz ganz schlimm ist was
sagen sie denn dazu zu diesem modell und
der vielleicht ja hier in gang eine
chance auch abstand zu schaffen ja aber
diese incidents von größer 200 das wurde
ja auch gesagt die haben wir ja an
vielen stellen bereits von daher ist es
auch an vielen stellen wie sie sagen
ganz ganz schlimm
hier wurde das so dargestellt dass
dieses wechselmodell quasi eine maßnahme
in einem bunten blumenstrauß sein von
denen man jetzt auswählen könne als eins
der bundesländer was sich entscheidet wo
etwas zu tun oder landkreise die
betroffen sind
ich würde dann doch sagen wenn die
instanzen tatsächlich so hoch sind wie
in diesen hot spots regionen kann man
das machen man muss aber eben immer
schauen wie man das ganze gut begleitet
dass man eben dann digitale
möglichkeiten tatsächlich zur verfügung
stellt oder aus bereich räume oder
zusätzliches pädagogisches personal was
dann auch die situation aufgreifen kann
dass wir natürlich dann getrennte
gruppen haben die raum brauchen in dem
sie sich aufhalten oder ein lehrer
brauchen der auch die betreut
beziehungsweise zu hause dann auch im
homeschooling tatsächlich entsprechend
ausgestattet sind dass sie auch effektiv
dort lernen können ganz abseits dessen
dass sie auch zu hause natürlich in
mindestens in den niedrigeren klassen
auch betreuung
bräuchten wir uns gemeinsam gehört ja
auch in der pressekonferenz
der impfstoff das ist eben eine hoffnung
gleichzeitig wurde auch gesagt naja das
dauert auch noch bis der kann ja auch
nicht mal eben an einem tag verteilt
werden wir haben die frage oder mehrere
fragen schon gehabt wann kommt denn der
impfstoff und wird dann eine art
impfpflicht eingeführt was wissen sie
was schätzen sie also es wurde immer
ganz deutlich gesagt eine impfpflicht
wird es nicht geben und ich halte dass
diese zusage auch für war es wird ein
impfangebot geben an die bevölkerung und
wir werden uns zunächst glaube ich eher
in der situation sehen dass wir zu wenig
impfstoff haben um alle sofort impfen zu
können und wir werden auch zu wenig
personal haben um alle gleichzeitig zu
impfen das wird gestaffelt sein müssen
da gibt es ja schon überlegungen wie man
da priorisiert wen man da zunächst also
risikogruppen beispielsweise das heißt
vor allen dingen eben ältere personen
den pflegeheimen aber das wird ein
baustein sein der uns helfen kann diese
pandemie einzugrenzen aber das wird
tatsächlich nicht sein was von jetzt auf
gleich uns befreien wird von allen
anderen maßnahmen diese asl regel die
wird weiter ihre gültigkeit
nichtsdestotrotz behalten der zimmer
eben beim thema wie lange wird das
dauern nicht nur wann wird der impfstoff
kommen sondern wie lange werden
maßnahmen wohl dauern um auf dieses ziel
oder ziel zu erreichen um auf eine
instanz von unter 50 zu kommen da
schreibt ralf cramer über e-mail wie
lange soll denn der lock down oder
shutdown eben die ganzen maßnahmen
dauern
diese institute von 50 erreicht man ja
lange nicht einfach mal so schnell was
schätzen sie also jetzt haben wir gehört
dass geht mindestens bis zum januar
diese maßen haben und je nachdem wie
intensiv die länder jetzt tatsächlich
aus diesen möglichkeiten auswählen und
was alles dann umgesetzt wird denke ich
dass er gegebenenfalls auch noch länger
dauern wird also je weniger wir an
maßnahmen jetzt mal
desto länger werden wir maßnahmen
benötigen dann sind wir genau bei der
frage von christian türken der ball über
facebook schreibt reicht das was bund
und länder beschlossen haben oder ist
eine chance vielleicht vertan jetzt
härtere massnahmen zu treffen um damit
tatsächlich dem ziel auch etwas näher zu
kommen
ja es ist für mich jetzt tatsächlich
noch ein bisschen schwer einschätzbar
weil ich eben nicht weiß in welchem ob
die länder das jetzt maximal ausnutzen
was sie an möglichkeiten haben oder ob
sie mehr den minimalen weg wählen
da gibt es jetzt sozusagen ganz breites
spektrum wie das tatsächlich
ausgestaltet werden kann von seiten der
länder
ich denke irgendwie vorhin schon gesagt
dass aufgrund dessen dass ich nicht
davon ausgehe dass er das maximale
wählen werden dass ich eher skeptisch
bin dass das tatsächlich jetzt ausreicht
um im januar auch irgendwelche
lockerungen zu machen greifen mal so
kleine details raus die eben in der
beschlussvorlage eben standen oder jetzt
auch erwähnt worden beschlossen sind ffb
zwei masken 15 war die rede von 15 war
die rede an menschen in pflegeheimen
krankenhäusern senioren um über den
winter zu kommen
das würde ungefähr heißen einer fft zwei
maske pro winter woche würden sie sagen
ist das sinnvoll ist das viel zu wenig
oder zumindest eine maßnahme die
sinnvoll ist aus biologischer sicht also
ffp zwei masken können ja vor
infektionen schützen von daher ist wenn
ich die zugänglich mache habe ich
natürlich wieder ein mittel um die
infektionszahlen auch zu senken wenn
diese masken auch tatsächlich angewendet
werden und auch richtig angewendet
werden
man muss sich aber überlegen an wen
verteile ich das denn dann überhaupt es
gibt ja berechnungen dass das über 20
millionen personen sein müssen die dann
mit solchen masken ausgestattet werden
und das natürlich erstmal logistische
herausforderung an diese ganzen personen
dann die masken tatsächlich auszuliefern
sind wir beim thema masken es gibt leute
die keine masken tragen die korona
leugnen gegenmaßnahmen demonstrieren was
ist mit diesem querdenkern schreibt
sabine herzog über youtube warum sonst
solche demos erlaubt sind nun sind sie
keine ministerpräsident
aber was geht ihnen als virologin durch
den kopf wenn sie diese demonstrationen
sehen wo wirklich dann hunderte oder
tausende in berlin in leipzig
demonstrieren keine maske tragen ja nun
bin ich jetzt selbst in leipzig und wir
hatten also eine demonstration kürzlich
nicht nur eine sondern dann auch eine
zweite dazu ich habe da großes
unverständnis für wie man so
leichtfertig umgehen kann mit der
gesundheit von sich selbst aber vor
allen dingen auch mit der gesundheit von
den anderen das erschließt sich mir
nicht und ich wie gesagt habe dafür
keinerlei verständnis ich bin sehr dafür
dass man in kommunikation geht ich kann
auch sehr gut nachvollziehen dass man
das freiheitsrechte ein hohes gut sind
in deutschland aber das ist für mich der
absolut falsche weg darauf hinzuweisen
wir kommen noch mal auf das thema schule
das hat nicht nur kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten heute stunden
beschäftigt melanie döblitz schreibt via
e-mail ich bin eigentlich nur
fassungslos jede konferenz sitze ich von
der spannung da und höre dann nur
appelle oder h+ lüften als maßnahme als
vorschlag seit märz gibt es
schulbezogenen kein konzept außer der
regel plus lüften als eingesetzte person
an einer grundschule kann ich dieses
nicht handeln sagt sie einfach nur noch
schwer hinnehmen und ertragen ich frage
mich wo da der gesundheitsschutz für
alle beteiligten personen in der schule
bleibt also sie haben schon gesagt man
könnte wahrscheinlich an den schulen
mehr machen aber es ist nicht
durchgesetzt worden von den ländern so
scheint es jetzt zumal aber man muss
natürlich sagen auch wenn das die userin
dort anders sieht aha + l ist natürlich
per se nicht schlecht ist sondern da
kann man eigentlich auch eine menge mit
erreichen wenn es konsequent umgesetzt
wird und wenn vor allen dingen aber auch
an den schulen die voraussetzungen
geschaffen werden dass man es umsetzen
kann dann sahen wir ein großes
dankeschön an sie frau pietsch grüße
nach leipzig vielen dank dass sie mit
uns gemeinsam gewartet haben auf die
pressekonferenz
aber es ist ja eine spannende sache
gewesen und entscheidet jetzt wie es in
den nächsten wochen weitergeht vielen
dank für ihre einschätzungen grüße nach
leipzig ja und wir bedanken uns bei
ihnen ganz herzlich für ihr interesse
das sie gemeinsam mit uns die
pressekonferenz verfolgt haben was die
kanzlerin
der regierende bürgermeister von berlin
müller und der ministerpräsident von
bayern söder zusammengefasst haben die
ergebnisse des bund länder corona
gipfels der nun sozusagen die nächsten
wochen im winter für uns bestimmt die
ergebnisse vielen dank für ihr interesse
tschüss und schönen abend noch